felines don't always uh do what you want
them to do I can be a lot harder than
Taylor made it look I I will you I dare
you to try this would you do this well I
do have multiple cats I have I just
drooled when I said that um I have four
cats so I certainly could pick a cat and
try it okay let's do it right now do it
come out here we have your cat I want to
see you do
this
so oh gosh okay Peach okay
okay this is good yeah Peach just get
your arm over there there you go you can
do it you can do it you're doing great
Peach you're doing great you're doing
it okay oh no okay Peach is like look
what you made me
do
um I want I I see why people have a hard
time doing that